[Musique]
ces deux méthodes de stockage mais le
retour
[Musique]
on est à trois cents mètres sous terre
dans un laboratoire qui était creusé
uniquement pour la recherche
scientifique
on se trouve dans des roches argileuses
qui sont donc les roches qui sont
considérés comme futur rush d'accueil
pour le stockage des déchets radioactifs
en tout cas pour la suisse mais beaucoup
de pays européens et dans le monde
envisagent aussi les roches argileuses
comme roche d'accueil pourront fuir nos
déchets radioactifs un futur
pas facile facile car l'épaisseur licite
futur mari joue à notre 6 1 6 2
[Musique]
c'est à dire on simule toutes les phases
que ce soit la phase de construction de
mise en place des déchets le scellement
des galeries la phase de monitoring et
ensuite on simule tous les effets
physico chimiques qui peuvent se passer
dans un stockage donc d'essayer de
comprendre tous les effets qui peuvent
se produire sur un stockage dont la
durée est estimée à peu près un million
d'années puisque c'est la durée pour
laquelle on doit rassurer un confinement
sur pour la radioactivité
pour
non
[Musique]
pourquoi
elles sont
m
politesse inti radioactive n'appelle pas
cela
vaudra à fabien
ehrhart outre à charleville qui marque
ce sont trois manades philippe au
roaming marque à ockrent la réalité
cette date du magasin tati
[Musique]
oui
pratique